what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest one piece chapter
and this was the most hyped chapter in
recent memory it just doesn't get better
or more legendary than this
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing one piece reviews
on this channel and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is hit that like button really
smash it and share this video with your
not come up if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos make this the day you subscribe
if you haven't already and while you
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist where i got videos about the
supernova the warlords the yonko
and much much more link in the
description also check out my recent one
piece video
and longest video in the channel's
history where i look at every yonko's
backstory
check the link in the description for
that now without further ado let's jump
into it
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called
flames which is an apt title because it
is straight fire
we got a nice requested cover art where
and i'll just quote it because it's
pretty hilarious
a raccoon buddhist priest repeatedly
smacks
sanji who continues to have worldly
thoughts during zen meditation end quote
i love this because a
it's hilarious b i'm into meditation and
zen philosophy and c
i'm also very into girls like nami as
well and i gotta admit i often start
thinking of quote-unquote worldly
thoughts
when i'm meditating especially during
this month so i can relate hardcore to
this
all in all a beautiful and relatable
cover story
but moving on to the epic chapter itself
so we get sanji running to what we all
assumed
to be black maria and that is a meeting
i've been waiting for for a long time
sanji reacting to a woman as beautiful
as black maria
is sure to be good and only now do we
realize how important it was that jinbe
was with luffy as well as sanji
sanji straight up left luffy to save a
woman which is not a bad thing
it's in alignment with sanji's character
he's a gentleman in his own way
and when it sounds like a woman is in
trouble it only makes sense that he goes
to help her i'm not holding this against
sanji at all but it does
show how indispensable jinbe is here as
part of the crew in this instance
so he can support luffy even when sanji
must leave to protect the maiden's
purity and do other sanji things
with the way oda set up sanji's
character i don't think anybody can be
surprised by his
decision here for him it seems like
someone is forcing themselves on a lady
against her wishes
he hears the woman begging the man to
stop so you know
sanji's gonna try to save her as is
mentioned in the manga it's not just her
clothes she's about to lose but her
purity as well
knight in shining armor sanji has heard
enough he breaks through the walls only
to get caught in a spiderweb trap black
maria definitely seems to be giving off
that black widow vibe
black widow spiders are known in pop
culture for eating
killing their mates so she definitely
spells danger for dudes
who get close to her and that may even
include kaido but we shall see as it
turns out this was all
a trap by black maria's people they set
up the whole performance to trap quote
unquote
naive warriors of justice which is
pretty hilarious
does it seem a bit sad that they caught
black like sanji with his 330 million
bounty this way
kind of but i still respect sanji he
didn't know for sure it was a trap so he
had to follow his own principles
he lived by his own code of honor and
that's respectable
even if he did end up being tricked then
we finally get the meeting between the
beautiful black maria and the tied up
sanji
she kindly asks sanji not to cause
trouble so that the banquet hall
doesn't become a battlefield and she
says that she has a soft spot for
foul-mouthed boys like
sanji she asks if sanji likes her and
after he makes it clear that he's not
happy with being tied up beat up
and belittled he appears to say that
he's nonetheless
lovestruck which is hilarious and
quintessential sanji right there
very much looking forward to seeing how
this develops and let's not be too
quick to judge this being a mistake on
sanji's part sanji might actually prove
to be very useful in perhaps swaying
black maria
or using his position to the straw hat
crew's advantage
we'll need to have the full picture
before we can judge sanji
being here as a bad thing that would be
the zen buddhist way to look at it after
all
then we jump to jinbei and luffy and
although they notice sanji is missing
they don't blame him for it
or spend too much time thinking about it
i'm sure luffy trusts him like a true
captain trusts his
crew members we got some more irrelevant
and comedic headliners being introduced
including mazurka
with her awkward gorilla smile that
drops banana crumbs on her
and poker the man with rattlesnake parts
coming out of his shoulders
these smile users definitely end up
manifesting their animal powers in very
weird and comedic ways
as poker the rattlesnake man waits on
the stairs and is fantasizing about
catching the straw hats and being
promoted to the flying six
we figure out that luffy is not even
gonna pass the stairs
these guys aren't even gonna be
one-shotted by our guys but just
completely ignore it all together
anyways allies made a ladder for luffy
and jimbei
so they could climb to the fourth floor
without passing the stairs where so many
people are waiting for them it's pretty
hilarious too and i wonder if these
extras will just wait there for the rest
of the battle on the stairs
inside the dome where zorro and friends
are they see
big mom heading off to the roof and
let's just be glad that they don't have
to take on big mom right now
zoro has an interesting moment where in
the middle of all this pandemonium and
panic he becomes pretty
stoic if you will keep in mind this
whole time apu was seemingly dodging
attacks from zorro and drake combined
not to mention running from everybody
else drake is still engaging him in
battle
while queen laughs his butt off telling
apoo to run like the win so he can amuse
him
again queen's over here like he's
playing a game and everyone here is his
pawn
however zorro had enough you're not
going to make zorro into a pawn
he slices apu in an epic panel quickly
sheathing his sword afterwards
this is some epic samurai stuff right
here now even though
they're all supernovas i will say i
think zoro is definitely stronger than
apu but we must acknowledge that apu was
distracted by drake and as a result
probably didn't see the quick slash
coming still that doesn't take away from
how epic and fast
zorro had to be to finish him off so
quick he gets the antidote for the ice
virus
and passes it off to chopper who
remember is infected
we have a nice moment where the usually
stoic zorro
asks chopper if he can handle this floor
and says to him and i quote you're not
gonna die right
end quote and chopper says of course not
our reindeer is taking charge of the
situation bravely
and says he's already figured out the
composition of the virus
we get a nice smile from zorro as he
says that's our dock
you usually associate zoro with being a
sort of tsundere
and fighting with people like sanji even
if he cares about them he has a kind of
distant tough love approach with his
nakama
most of the time but here we get a
genuinely nice moment between these two
and i love it
now chopper gets his chance to shine as
he takes control of the situation
and tells everyone to counter the ice
demon virus with fire to stop the
spreading until he can make enough
antibodies for
everyone and that's right everyone
including allies and enemies
chopra is living by his own code of
honor and he as a doctor
is obligated to save both allies and
enemies alike and this
is where we could really see guys
switching sides when queen treats them
so bad and their enemy is offering to
save their lives
again i want to see some antagonists
just treating all their crew members
good too
obviously kaido had that moment with
jack and i thought it was great
we don't want every villain to be just
like early vegeta
ready to kill his own partner nappa at
the drop of a hat
i personally prefer a bit more gray area
between the protagonists and antagonists
but that said when really unlikable
people like queen
do get their just desserts it is all the
more satisfying because of how awful
they are
just as queen the all-star is getting
ready to end the lives of his own
supernova apoo
and chopper his gun gets cut apart to
his shock
and it turns out to be our boy zorro as
if he wasn't epic enough already in this
chapter
he tells the all-star that he didn't
come to onigashima to play his games but
to cut down
kaido the one known as the strongest
in the world that moment gives me
goosebumps
it's so epic and legendary this is even
better than cutting down
apu as he not only attacks and talks
back at an
all-star here he straight up says he
came here to cut down a yonko
and the strongest one in the world at
that and i'm really glad to see it
i think there's plenty more that zoro
has been holding back
and an all-star is definitely a more
fitting opponent for him than a poo
in my view and he may not even stop
there because he clearly plans to cut
down kaido
again i don't think anyone thinks that
he'll beat kaido alone but as a part of
a team
effort i could see that there's been
plenty of foreshadowing already that
will get to see zoro have a go at kaido
with his swords
the weapon that seems to be the most
effective against this old and
traumatized yonko
and while zoro says this epic stuff an
earthquake happens
perfect timing by the way people think
it's the result of his rage and it's
questioned if it's conqueror's hockey
zora explains calmly that that obviously
wasn't him but it's definitely a fun
moment where oda is having some fun with
the readers who are dying to know
if zorro will end up having conquerors
haki not that he even needs it to be a
legend at this point and it turns out
the thing that made zoro upset
all of a sudden as robin points out was
kiku's arm falling from the ceiling and
that is quite the crazy thing to witness
in the middle of a battle
zoro wishes he could just fly up there
but knows
with queen and king there that it won't
be easy whichever way he gets up
and then marco comes offering to help
the straw hats
marco taking on king and zorro taking on
queen
i think that could be pretty epic before
zoro reaches kaido but we'll see
the point is with marco here and big mom
not in a poo
down things are definitely looking a lot
better for our side in this area we get
a cute moment of tama
saying she's scared only to catch
herself and say i'm not scared at all
i love that moment and nami is with her
wondering about the earthquake too
and then we see luffy and jimbei also
wondering about the earthquake it turns
out the island is shaking
and things just keep getting more and
more interesting as everyone is reacting
we get yamato
wanting to get momo on a ship to safety
but not even the sea
is where it's supposed to be then yamato
reveals some crazy stuff like that they
lost their chance to escape by sea
and that dragons can generate flame
clouds which enable them to fly
and right now kaido is lifting onigima
itself
using that power so pretty much everyone
here
is kaido's hostage right now so we got a
floating island
info on dragons rather than dragon fruit
powers suggesting again that kaido could
actually be some sort of dragon
it's crazy stuff and we'll know even
more based on the official translations
but right now it seems that kaido is
using his insane powers to take his huge
floating island to the flower capital
the people of wano and the kozuki
by extension will be finished as kaido
seemingly plans to drop this
island on onigashima creating the new
onigima and wiping out the people of
wano in the process
then yuu onigishima will be the perfect
stronghold for pirates and with this
kaido wants to begin a world of mayhem
kaido is clearly not being held back by
any sorts of morals at this point
and is ready to kill countless people it
seems like
it raises the stakes big time as well as
the urgency
and that is it for this epic chapter
zorro flexed in a legendary way
absolutely legendary but kaido had his
flex too
he turned an island into kaido's flying
castle and that was epic in its own
right
not gonna lie i am excited to see what
happens next and to learn more about
kaido's motivations and powers can't
wait to see
zorro get serious too and for the
confrontation with kaido to begin
clearly the scabbards are no longer
putting up a fight against kaido
which means as we may have guessed it's
going to come down to luffy and the
other pirates to take him down but yeah
in the comments let me know what you
thought about this one and what you
expect to see happening next definitely
one of my favorite chapters
with one of my favorite zorro moments to
date if you did enjoy this review and
want to keep the one piece reviews
coming the best thing you could do is
hit that like button really smash it and
share this video with your not come up
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
where i got videos about pretty much
anything you can imagine including the
supernova
the warlords the yonko and much much
more link in the description
and specifically check out my longest
video ever on
every yonko's backstory if you haven't
since as you'd expect the way these
yonko got to where they are
is fascinating af and i especially want
to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twego himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans ingrata the
world
acquire respect liam thompson pate heffa
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinnell
big buddhist rythean tungsten tarkis
and denki kaminari and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh who's
the current most donated overall
champion of the world
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatski
cricket xp
joel stanton rathu and de ora very gucci
jessica kayla font alicia actor hinokami
and water bonnie parks the red haired
raven florian
joanne garcia mcshamus jack watches
anime amanda c
deadly saint high school dxd73 matthew
cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support mormon by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patronly discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already smashed
and a bunch of you have been doing that
so thank you so much to everyone who's
joined the channel as well
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer so whichever way
you support us you can get the same
great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you